onwards Chloe hold on hi hello hi did oh
wow
great Monday's perfect okay thank you
bye
Chloe I got the job we got the job we
got the job we got the job we got I got
the job what am I gonna do about you
pink wine nothin
got it princess Pig for sure yeah what
about the blue nope how about this guy
awesome thank you for your input Chloe
and now it is complete Madame Chloe I
present to you my crowning achievement
my opus puppy corner pretty cool huh
come on in make yourself at home but
it's got all the stuff you like a
favorite toys there's a picture of me in
case you get lonely this is your space
whatever you say goes as long as it's in
puppy corner and the pee is on the pad -
the best part is puppy camp go I'm gonna
check in on you while I'm at work don't
be worried just wait for me and that's
gonna seem like a long time but that's
just because you're a puppy and you
don't understand time bye Clark I love
you
clearly where are you excuse me
did you need something um no sorry I was
uh talking to my puppy okay I'll see you
later
Chloe anyone the one flaw of puppy
corner and you found it shoots that's a
dog um yeah is she bothering you you're
not allergic are you nope
and she's not helping you or helping me
you don't need her for medical reasons
you brought her into the office and
she's your dog and that's just cool
all right so we have 30 minutes and then
we gotta get back to work
you just like home